sixteen hours after belarusian
opposition leader maria kolesnikova was
abducted on the streets of minsk
a car pulls up at the border with
ukraine it's four am
according to the belarussian version of
events the car sped up
endangering the life of a border guard
before kolesnikova was thrown out of it
by her colleagues
now in kiev they tell a very different
story
they say they were told they would face
criminal prosecution and jail terms
unless they agreed to leave for ukraine
but that kolesnikova had refused to
cross the border that she'd ripped up
her passport saying she was not going
anywhere
in minsk supporters of kolesnikova came
out chanting her name
until true to form balaclavad men in
military uniforms started picking out
protesters one by one
and dragging them away
[Music]
kalesnikov's teammate veronica told us
from warsaw that what is happening in
belarus carries echoes from the nazi
past
it's a heart breaking when you see this
story when you hear the stories when you
see how kashanka tortures people how he
beats them up how is it for me for his
concentration camps
i thought this concentration camp here
was uh
over 70 years ago but apparently in
dallas we still have concentration camps
president lukashenko spoke today with
russian state media ahead of a trip to
moscow in the coming days
i must protect what was created by our
hands protect those people who created
it
as this is the overwhelming majority the
majority voted for me
despite them seeing me every day
everywhere the iron the tv
the refrigerator maybe somewhere they
got bored
but they supported me
[Music]
say she was taken in this convoy from a
military unit near the ukrainian border
the belarusian authorities have not said
where they're taking her
but even as lukashenko picks off the
opposition one by one
the crowds come out determined to keep
the pressure on the leader
they no longer want danny mcnay sky news
moscow